[MUSIC PLAYING]
EMILY PRICE: Hi everybody.
I'm Emily Price.
And I'm a product
manager for Google VR.
I'm here today to talk with you
about interactive storytelling
using two of the
products that I work on.
So you just heard from
my colleague Michael
about VR and AR at
Google, which we
believe is the fourth wave
of computing that is here,
it's coming, and it's really
important for developers.
So just as a quick
poll, how many of you
have tried Daydream?
Oh man, that's a lot of you.
How many of you have
experience with VR?
That's even more, yes.
So for those of you
who haven't, I'm
going to assign you
some homework right now.
So by the end of
the week, you need
to drop by the Google booth and
try some of the Daydream demos
we have there.
There are some things that
I really want all of you
to understand about VR
before you leave GDC.
Why do we think and why do I
believe VR is so important?
VR is going to change the
way that we tell stories.
VR gives you the ability to
break out of the single frame
and tell a story that unfolds
everywhere around you.
And there are three things
that, for me, really
make VR storytelling different.
The first one is immersion.
So when you're taking control
of people's optical cortex
and all of their senses,
you're putting them inside
of a story in a
completely new way.
The second one is agency.
So when you start giving
people the ability to interact
and they're fully immersed
and present in the space,
you have a whole new type
of superhero narrative.
You are the hero in a
completely different way
than you are on a flat screen.
And the third thing is that VR
is really about sharing worlds.
We have the ability to
take you and transport you
to another planet, or somewhere
amazing on this planet.
Or we have the ability to share
the places in the world that
are really important
to us and tell stories
about those places
that are really
beautiful and meaningful.
And so when it comes to the
idea of sharing the world,
that's really where I come in.
So I work on Google Jump,
which is a VR camera
system from Google.
I've got one here on the stage
if people want to check it out.
And what we're really
about is we're all
about giving people the tools to
capture the world and share it.
So when I say camera system,
I can mean two things.
The first one is
the camera itself.
We partnered with GoPro
to make the GoPro Odyssey.
And so what the
GoPro Odyssey is,
it's 16 standard
off-the-rack GoPro cameras,
arranged in a ring
with custom firmware
so that they are synchronized.
And they run off
of a shared battery
so you don't have to
charge all 16 of them
and lose one in the
middle of filming.
And here's a quick photo of
me going out and capturing
a place that's important to me.
I really love
post-apocalyptic stories,
and so I went out and filmed
some good post-apocalyptic
scenery.
So the first part
really is the camera
that allows you to
go out and capture.
And the second thing that we do
is we do automated stitching.
So we designed this camera
to capture the world
in omnidirectional stereo.
So the 20 second introduction
to omnidirectional stereo
is if you think about all of
the light in front of you,
capturing all of that light
and turning around in a circle
and capturing all
of that light too,
we designed the camera to
capture the world in that way.
And we take the 16 different
videos off of the GoPro
Odyssey, and we stitch
them together in the cloud.
We blow apart all the
pixels and put them
back together to create a
perfect 360 3D stereo video.
It's pretty awesome.
I think I have some
demos on my phone
if you really want to see it.
So OK.
So what am I doing here?
Why am I here at GDC
talking about VR video?
It's because my favorite games--
I love games, I
believe in games.
My favorite games are the ones
that are all about the stories.
I love narrative game design.
I love narrative-based games.
And I think that when it comes
to telling stories in VR,
bringing together,
capturing the world
with narrative-based games and
narrative-based game design
is going to unlock some of
the killer apps and killer
stories of the medium.
So I'm really here
looking for people
who are interested in
telling those sort of stories
that are planning
projects around telling
those types of stories.
And I would love to talk to you.
So if this sounds
like your project,
if you're looking at blending VR
video and interactivity to tell
a story, I want to talk to you.
I want to help you.
So if this sounds like
you, please get in touch,
please come find me.
I'll be here all week, I have
pink hair, I work for Google.
And I would love to talk with
you further about VR video
interactivity and storytelling.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]